salut après un an et demi de vidéos de
spectacles et d'écriture de livres j'ai
décidé de faire une pause cet été pour
me reposer oui mais aussi pour vous
préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en
septembre vous est demandé sur twitter
si vous vouliez quelques facteurs rapide
et divertissant en attendant alors
pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous
laisse une vidéo rapide et sans
prétention tous les jours pairs à 11
heures on se retrouve à la rentrée et
tout de suite ça lui aujourd'hui on se
refait une petite énigme dans cette
énigme ya un contexte vous allez imaginé
deux youtuber qui ont trois actions à
faire et ça c'est pour apporter un
nouveau challenge qui aura mis en place
youtube imaginons ya le montage d'une
vidéo à faire sur un ordinateur il ya qu
un seul ordinateur il faut également
tourné une vidéo il ya qu une seule
caméra il faut également écrire une
vidéo et il ya qu un seul carnet avec un
seul stylo pour écrire la vidéo chacune
de ces tâches le tournage le montage et
l'écriture prend exactement une heure si
elle est faite par une seule personne
le challenge va commencer et ils ont
sans minutes pour réaliser l'ensemble
des tâches 100 minutes pas une de plus
ma question est est ce que déjà ils ont
une possibilité de réussir le challenge
sans l'aide de personne parce que je
vous rappelle qu'il ya une vidéo à faire
il n'y a qu'une seule caméra il faut
écrire une autre vidéo il ya qu un seul
carnet avec un seul stylo et il faut
monter une vidéo il ya qu un seul
ordinateur chacune de ses actions si
elle est faite par une seule personne
prend une heure et ils ont 100 minutes
pour tout faire est ce que c'est
possible si oui comment chercher bien
alors attention si vous voulez chercher
n'hésitez pas à quitter la vidéo
maintenant et à revenir plus tard ou à
mettre sur pause parce que là je vais
pas tarder à donner la réponse
et comme toujours pour les énigmes et
c'est oui toi de retenir ta main qui a
envie de donner des trucs et des
réponses dans les commentaires
attention répondants 3-2-1 maintenant
alors la réponse et vous vous dites déjà
ils peuvent remporter le challenge snow
se servir à rien maintenant c'est
comment qui nous intéresse si les deux
youtuber se mettent chacun sur une tâche
durant une heure ils seront forcément à
voir puisque à la fin il restera plus
que 40 minutes
et comme chaque action peut être fait
que par une personne une seule personne
puisqu'il ya qu un seul ordinateur qu
une seule caméra car seul carnet et
qu'il faut 60 minutes pour réaliser une
action ils peuvent pas la faire mais il
ya une alternative qui va leur permettre
de même avoir dix minutes d'avancé avant
la fin il faut que le premier youtuber
commence à faire une vidéo pendant 30
minutes pendant qu'en simultané l'autre
youtuber écrit une vidéo pendant 30
minutes au bout de ces trente minutes le
premier youtuber passe à l'écriture de
la vidéo pendant encore trente minutes
tandis que le youtuber deux passes au
montage de la vidéo pendant 30 minutes
et font donc ça simultanément pendant 30
minutes à la fin de cette trente minutes
donc on est à 60 minutes de youtube eur
2 qui était en moi
je passe au tournage pour 30 minutes le
youtube eur 1 qui lui étaient en
écriture passe au montage donc pendant
30 minutes aussi également toujours de
manière simultanée
et là c'est terminé puisque aura eu deux
fois trente minutes au montage deux fois
trente minutes à l'écriture et deux fois
trente minutes au tournage donc ils ont
réalisé toutes les exactions en 90
minutes
ils ont gagné et bravo aussi si vous
aviez trouvé la bonne réponse si ça vous
a plu
n'oubliez pas le petit like de vous
abonner qu'elle ment si c'est pas encore
fait je vous rappelle que c'est une
vidéo tous les deux jours cet été
jusqu'au 30 août
c'est le principe de cet été un des
vidéos un petit peu plus courte mais
très régulièrement sur des sujets plus
légers et donc rendez-vous après demain
ciao
non